Britney Spears
is dancing around her home with knives
with big shark knives and Brittany since
her conservatorship has been lifted
Brittany has posted a lot of odd videos
half naked or naked dancing around
on Tick Tock and doing things that don't
seem particularly helpful to her
she's now denied this so you can see the
video playing around on Tick Tock she's
denied it though
and so I started playing in the kitchen
with knives today don't worry they're
not real knives
Halloween is soon
with three exclamation marks every time
but I look at those knives
they look pretty real they don't look
like plastic knives or anything to me
maybe they're fake maybe they're just
really really good fakes but I don't
know Britney's exhibited a ton of crazy
behavior in recent years and I guess
really for 15 years now
so I have to ask myself
was it really a good idea to free
Britney there's the free Brittany
movement when she was under a
conservatorship and the free Brittany
movement was based on this idea that
Brittany has the right to Liberty
just true we all we all want Liberty
Liberty is a good thing but the reason
the free Brittany movement was wrong is
because the the free Brittany movement
presupposed a definition of Liberty
based on choice not based on perfect
willing and understanding so this is a
very very important distinction if your
will is compromised
if you're a degenerate addict or
something
then you can't be granted
this kind of political Liberty and we
have programs in our justice system to
limit your political Liberty
and not even to limit your Liberty to
recognize that your Liberty is limited
and so they're going to constrain your
field of operation and politics if you
are ignorant if you if you're something
that's defective in your intellect
then your Liberty is going to be limited
this is why we have conservatorships
this is why we have legal Powers of
Attorney this is why we have parental
rights it's because little kids
aren't in control of their will and
aren't particularly educated yet and so
they don't get to vote
until the Democrats have their way and
they lower the voting age to five they
don't get to whatever drive a car they
don't get to participate in Civic life
it seems like a little bit of an
abstract issue well my definition of
Liberty is this and your definition of
Liberty that this this is a crucial
thing
Freedom Liberty is a defining feature
perhaps the defining feature of human
nature but the left and the right in
this country and frankly even there's a
disagreement of this on the on the right
we disagree over what that means and
until we figure out what that means if
we continue to persist in this false
Liberty which is nothing more than
Choice the country is going to continue
to degrade and we're going to be a whole
country of Britney Spears's right now go
to geniusell.com knowlesyt as you might
know we are all big fans of genucel over
here but you don't just need to take my
word for how great a company it is Ella
from Rockford says quote I have both age
and acne spots and this stuff is
actually fading both of them this Serum
is worth every penny Ella is raving
about the famous Dark Spot Corrector
from genucel a must-have after months of
record heat and humidity sunspots brown
spots discoloration even red inflamed
patches all disappear in front of your
very eyes here's the genucel amazing
guarantee you will see results on day
one or your money back so take advantage
of geniusell's most popular package
which now includes the Dark Spot
Corrector plus the classic geniusell
bags and puffiness treatment and
immediate effects all at about 70 70 off
so you can try the best skin care in the
world for yourself completely risk-free
it is simple go to
geniusell.comyt letter y letter T start
looking years even decades younger
tomorrow say goodbye to dark and liver
spots bags and puffiness under the eyes
crow's feet at genucel.com knowlesyt
that is genusell.com
Knowles YT the Wuhan Institute of
virology says that another coronavirus
outbreak is highly likely
and they would know weren't wouldn't
they study published by scientists at
the Wuhan Institute in July reportedly
circulating widely on Chinese social
media has concluded that as many as 20
species of coronavirus are highly likely
to cause an outbreak among humans
right about on time yeah
yeah that's
because you see the election is in about
13 months so this is right right about
on time this study appeared in emerging
microbes and infections in July the
South China Morning Post noted but it
began making headlines in Chinese
language media as social media users
discovered it and began spreading its
conclusions online what are they saying
they're saying quote this is according
to the study it is almost certain that
there will be future disease emergence
and is highly likely a COV coronavirus
disease again thus the early preparation
for the animal kovies with risk of
spillover is important for future
disease preparedness regarding the
likely animal origin of SARS MERS and
covet 19. I don't want to sound like a
conspiracy theorist I didn't bring my
tinfoil hat with me to Washington DC
you remember right before the outbreak
of kovid there was that big
exercise with scientists and government
officials and ngos where they they just
did a test run of what it would look
like if a coronavirus spread throughout
the world and caused a mass pandemic and
a shutdown of governments and economies
you know and then it just happened
almost immediately thereafter
it would seem reasonable to conclude
from such an exercise that uh
something was likely to happen well I
think that's what we're seeing here
they're telling us what's going to
happen and you can you can take the most
extreme view of it and say they're
planning it and they're intentionally
going to release it and it's going to
it's to shut down the election or you
could just say yeah look they're
the Wuhan Institute of virology is just
like all human institutions is kind of
weak and fallen and when you're dealing
with very dangerous things sometimes
they leak and we're just there it's a
prediction rather than a promise either
way maybe you're somewhere in the middle
between those two poles either way
I think I think covet is going to happen
again are the people willing to go along
with it
I have friends of mine conservative
friends who live through 2020 2021 2022
who insist oh Michael
the people will never go along with
covet again
what are you talking about
no Michael them did they learn their
lesson you think they learned their
lesson no they didn't I have liberal
friends who are wearing masks right now
already they're not even mandated yet
even after we were told the masks don't
really work even after we were told that
the vaccines don't really work even
after we were told that the social
distancing was completely arbitrary
they're already doing it again
people's memories are very very short
and people just kind of Follow the
Leader
that's why political power is so
important is we're not all just hyper
individualists who you know form all of
our own conclusions and write long
treatises about about what we think
about every aspect of society if that
were true we wouldn't get out of bed in
the morning
people just basically followed the
leader in the established powers and the
established Powers over in China China
and here in the United States and the
fauces and the nihs and the public
health officials in New York and
Lionsgate in California and the Morris
Brown College in Atlanta and Rutgers in
New Jersey they're all just starting to
do covet again
and
people probably will just go along with
it boy what a great clip that was now
make sure that you ring the bell
subscribe to Michael Knowles Channel see
you next time